that meal was 2,000 milligrams of sodium
flashes of just being prepared for
disasters is something that is important
for people across the globe the American
Red Cross and FEMA recommend putting
together a kit of supplies that last at
least 72 hours this includes
non-perishable easy to prepare food we
try to make it on one of these three-day
survival food kits so we're gonna be
doing the 72-hour survival food
challenge for the next three days we're
only going to be eating emergency food
and it's only supposed to last three
days in hopes that someone will look
kind of save us I think I have a little
bit of survivalist give me I'm the kind
of person who always wants to be
prepared I can weave rope but I don't
have emergency food supplies especially
we're in California so there's gonna be
an earthquake soon it sounds like and
there's just disasters happening
everywhere I just want to be ready
it looks like Easy Mac carefully add two
cups of boiling water I have to wait
eight to nine minutes but I think I'm
going to eat it in four it smells pretty
home-cooked I think I approve I like it
a lot this is great I'm really excited
welcome back to cooking in bags with
Maggie this is my dinner today it's an
old family recipe it reminds me of my
college cafeteria food really freaking
good how is it
okay but I do need it back for my
calories this is actually really good
just a little bit not so good it's lunch
time it's the beef stroganoff I don't
know what stroganoff is but it sounds
good lunch time lunch time was where
things went all wrong
there this one is pretty high in sodium
so as I'm finishing the beef stroganoff
I'm hitting a wall where it just feels
very creamy my chest is like
uncomfortable in like this area and my
body just like went into like a weird
shock I don't want to throw up
no I hate throwing up I wonder how
Maggie is doing when if she's had the
beef stroganoff yet I came messaged me
and was like hey how are you doing have
you had the beef stroganoff yet and it
was like oh yeah
I'm sweating I don't know if it's the
heat or if it's the salt coursing
through my veins
then you guys like how do you feel I was
like weird have you weird
it's been a rough couple of days three
days two and a half I think it's just
the sodium that's getting to me really
you want fresh food right now
like just fresh food nothing free dried
please yeah I've been eating the whole
bag of all of this on the last day I I
want it to finish strong for lunch i
heated up the pasta primavera I ate half
of it and then I just could not eat
anymore
looked in the fridge and like grabbed
like the little bell pepper things where
you can just snack on the juiciest thing
I've ever eaten like I came alive from
eating that I could eat a whole head of
lettuce I just need something fresh I
feel like I still will definitely get
some of these for my emergency pack for
when I need it because at the end of the
day we struggled so much with this
because we're not in an emergency
situation
I still have shelter and clothes and an
Internet the only thing I'm having to
deal with right now is just the food in
emergency situations what we initially
see there's like probably ten more
issues that people are dealing with this
baby realized that I'm in a place right
now where I can actually help I'm gonna
donate some money to
it should be something that I do more
often but you can have a bad day you're
taking one down you sing